there's four things I pray about and I'm
struggling with one of them a lot lately
I pray for courage wisdom tolerance
understanding I do and those are four
things I need courage to do what I'm
doing on a daily basis family business
all this stuff I need wisdom because I'm
talking to people that are smarter than
me and I want to get as much wisdom from
them as possible so God's surrounding me
around smarter people than me that I'm
learning from everybody
tolerance is what I prayed for for the
longest time and then understanding to
be able to see the other side of the
argument somebody I disagree with or
disagrees with me on the tolerance side
uh it's to the point where I think
sometimes if you were to look at the
most tolerant denomination or
sect or religion you would say the most
tolerant religion is the
non-denominational Christian is who it
is okay
you would
have to say that because they're very
forgiven oh it's okay you know turn the
cheek or do this or do that okay and
we're seeing that the country in the
world with the least amount of lgbtq
members is Indonesia less than five
percent uh uh is is not not lgbtq
members Indonesia doesn't support
same-sex marriage less than five percent
of Indonesia support same-sex marriage I
think in America we're at 72 percent
give or take what the numbers that just
dropped off seven percent to it was 71
percent out 64 percent I think
Christians are part of the problem in
America
I think lazy Republicans are part of the
problem in America I think Libertarians
who are like man I don't give a
what you do just leave me alone let me
make my money as much as those are all
honorable type of things to look at I
think they're all part of the problem
because they don't realize that a part
of
a what Jesus or who they admired they
had a level of intolerance to compromise
certain values and principles they were
not from the mindset of it's okay it's
okay it's okay they were like no no I'm
not crossing the line here with you you
want to do that dude but you're wrong
and I disagree with you that's what
we're going to stand where it's more
like to each his own to each his own to
each his own and this concept of being
too tolerant has gotten America to for
to go from being the greatest country in
the world where we were fear respected
admired and secretly everybody kind of
wanted to be like us of course we're
hated anytime you're number one you're
gonna be hated who's the most hated
football quarterback of all time it's
very easy who's the most hated
basketball player of all time it's very
easy who's the most hated country of all
time it's very easy we were able to do
something these countries for two
thousand years a thousand years couldn't
do we did it in 150 years 200 years of
course you're going to hate that country
because it shows incompetence in your
philosophies and your ideas right so
I understand that but I kind of agree
with you where
I think the American people from those
three sects
the lazy Republicans the Libertarians
are like to each his own
into the two tolerant Christians that
are saying it's okay to everything
I think they've kind of compromised what
these 56 men brave men that started this
country with the reason why I'm here as
an immigrant from Iran they kind of hurt
that but anyways right at the end of the
podcast I'll give you the last word here
to you uh any final thoughts you have is
there any level of optimism for the
future because if someone's listening to
this right now they're probably moving
to Singapore some of the people that are
listening to this in America they're
saying maybe I go hide in a uh you know
place in uh Hawaii and Kauai in the
mountains with my family of six people
should I be optimistic or pessimistic
about the future
tolerance for the Intolerable is the
path to certain destruction
it has to end that's what's given us to
criminality and is reinforcing it
everywhere secondly if there are no
standards nothing works everything falls
apart
finally I would say yes there's reason
for optimism because there are a lot
more people out there listening to us
right now who know but what you've said
is true what I've said is true and are
willing to fight
when I say fight I don't necessarily
mean immediately pick up a gun but if
you can't vote your way out at some
point someone is going to suggest we're
going to have to find another way out
and I don't think we should exclude that
possibility I'm very disappointed in the
left because there are some good people
over there that should be more sensible
they should be concerned with voter
Integrity too but they're not right now
the people running the government the
people on the left the people in the on
the Rhino right are about power and
money and that's it
we've got to get back to where what's in
the interest of the American people we
don't have that right now I think RFK Jr
believes that I know Donald Trump
believes that can they work something
out between them can we build a third
party at this point I don't know
but that's the direction we need to go
are you confident with the Santas as
well as a candidate uh I don't know the
man but when I heard him speak very
logically and say we have no vital
strategic interest in eastern Ukraine
there's no reason for us to become
involved in a war there and then two
days later say oh I was wrong I guess
it's really important that we be there
it tells me he's donor focused
I don't want anybody who's donor focused
Donald Trump was never donor focused
happy Fourth of July too we have a
special event that's coming up with Tom
Brady Mike Tyson and we'll get there in
Miami Vault conference it'll be August
30th to September 2nd this weekend for
4th of July we're running a special buy
one get one free bring your spouse bring
your business partner bring your running
mate if you haven't yet registered click
on the link below or above get
registered looking forward to spending
three days with you in Miami
thank you
[Music]